estas son las quintas maniobras
militares que realizarán en las últimas
dos semanas la de hoy se realizó en las
cercanías del golfo de omán donde
fuerzas especiales se desplegaron en
helicópteros y aviones tratando de
simular un ataque a este país otras
maniobras han incluido también aquellos
misiles que tanta desconfianza causan en
washington y en los países vecinos del
golfo especialmente aquellos aliados de
eeuu el de mayor alcance se disparó a
una distancia de 1.800 kilómetros y cayó
en el norte del océano índico no muy
lejos de donde se encontraba el
portaaviones estadounidense nimitz a
sólo 160 km el general y comandante de
los guardias revolucionarios dijo hoy
que esto era un mensaje para demostrar
que irán estaba listo para defender su
territorio pero también aquí localmente
se ve como un mensaje de despedida al
presidente norteamericano donald trump
estos han sido cuatro años de gran
tensión entre ambos países ambos
estuvieron a punto de ir a una guerra en
varias ocasiones especialmente después
trump retirar a eeuu del acuerdo nuclear
en 2018 y prohibiera la venta de
petróleo iraní o el asesinato del
general iraní en suleimán y venir a que
en enero pasado